it is back to campus for most clark
county school district staff
today many teachers stepping inside
buildings for the first time in a year
since the beginning of distance
education
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
showing us the transition
at one local high school it's exciting
um
we've been waiting for this a big day
for jay tippett
getting ready for school this morning it
kind of felt like the first day of
school
the spring valley high school teacher
and coach returns to his classroom after
working remotely for a year
all the stuff that was on the walls was
still there
i had stuff from students that had
finished classes from
from the last school year and had
graduated he and his colleagues adjust
to coming back in buildings
and setting up for the start of hybrid
learning next monday
for grades 9 and 12. it was eerie
because there was no kids here
and not a lot of teachers roaming around
it feels like
those first three days that we would
have to go back to school set your
classroom up get ready for the students
administration here aims to ease the
transition with
welcome back swag bags gifts include a
pin with the school mascot wearing
a mask it was so exciting to see the
teachers carrying in their boxes
and setting up their cameras this
morning what's the percentage of staff
coming back and those deciding to stay
home
we have everyone here except for about
five people principal tam larnard says a
focus
this week includes setting up technology
he wants to ensure
cameras work and certain supplies come
in we bought
headphones for students if they don't
have them final preparations as
larner tippett and others return to a
certain routine and
some normalcy kristin drummond a news
now
that's been a long time spring valley
high school expecting roughly a thousand
students divided between cohorts a
and b coming back next week cohort a
will be on campus for
two courses monday and tuesday students
will then finish their school day
remotely and continue
online learning wednesday through friday
cohort b is the opposite
students attend class remotely monday
through wednesday and go to campus
thursday and
friday there will be